Eric Adams doubling down on identity
politics to sign a weight discrimination
bill into law you know everyone knows
that uh I'm a person that believes in
health
so when you talk about not
discriminating against someone because
of their body type is not fighting
against obesity it's just being fair and
so I think this is this is the right
thing to do we should we're going to
continue to talk about uh our
Progressive Health agenda and science
has shown that body type is not a
connection to if you're healthy or
unhealthy and I think that's a misnomer
that we are we are really dispelling
thank you
yeah yeah good is that good is that we
all know that isn't true